là
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 politique 7,8
politique un peu particulier ce soir
puisque nous sommes au parlement
européen de bruxelles tous les mois nous
allons rencontrer en europe le député
d'ile-de-france l'occasion de parler
avec lui d'europe évidemment l'europe
qui intervient dans notre vie à tous et
tous les jours nous évoquerons avec
notre invité l'actualité du vieux
continent le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes et nous vous
donnons la parole également pour que
vous puissiez interroger directement les
élus pour cette première ici à bruxelles
constance le grip heureux débuté les
républicains et d'ile-de-france nous
accompagnera nous parlerons notamment
avec elle de la crise syrienne et des
migrants dans cette émission va
découvrir aussi un père fondateur un peu
d'histoire pour parler du projet
européen jean monnet nous irons voir
aussi du côté de chez nos voisins les
différents régimes politiques qui sont
en vigueur en collaboration avec la
maison de l'europe des yvelines
d'ailleurs les yvelinois auront la
parole dans cette émission puisqu'ils
pourront poser leurs questions
directement à notre invité
constance les grilles bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes députée européenne depuis 2010
à l'époque vous aviez remplacer michel
barnier alors nommé commissaire européen
mais l'europe et vous c'est beaucoup
plus anciens puisque dès 1989
vous étiez attaché parlementaire d'alain
lamassoure eurodéputé toujours c'est un
sujet l'europe qui vous a toujours
passionné depuis votre plus jeune âge
vous vouliez faire une carrière
politique au sein des institutions
européennes
les enjeux européens m'ont toujours
passionné
effectivement la construction européenne
l'histoire de l'europe sont au coeur de
mes engagements depuis longtemps et
d'une sa femme hier également au coeur
de mon histoire familiale puisque je
suis née d'un mariage mixte
les parents ne venait pas des mêmes pays
ils n'avaient pas la même nationalité et
j'ai très longtemps vécu sur les bords
du rhin à strasbourg où j'ai notamment
vu en 1979 arrivée la première assemblée
parlementaire européenne issue du
suffrage universel direct c'était un
spectacle à la fois très impressionnant
et très émouvant est ce que j'ai
toujours voulu faire une carrière
politique européenne j'ai pas
l'impression d'être dans une carrière
politique européenne ou pas européenne
j'ai simplement l'impression d'être
fidèles et amis racines familiales et à
mes envies pour l'avenir en essayant
d'apporter ma très modeste contribution
à la construction européenne à la
construction européenne justement il en
est question tout de suite on va parler
d'histoire nous allons vous faire
découvrir le parcours de l'un des pères
fondateurs du vieux continent ce mois-ci
découvrons jean-monnet porteur du
premier projet européen la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier une
présentation en collaboration avec
philippe le guen le président le
directeur de l'association jean brunet
basée dans les yvelines
bien jean monnet au départ c'est un un
jeune homme qui est dans l'entreprise
familiale de son père négociant en
cognac donc vous voyez la bouteille de
cognac sur la table ça fait vraiment
symbole de l'homme qu'il était mais il a
eu un destin extraordinaire puisque de
négociants de cognac
il a été amené à travailler pendant la
première guerre mondiale avec les alliés
puis ensuite il est devenu un
il a une carrière internationale
d'abord dans la société des nations
ensuite il était banquier international
et puis par la seconde guerre mondiale
il a rejoint un rôle important et à la
fin de la guerre il a modernisé aussi la
france par le commissariat du plan qu'il
a inventé et puis en parallèle il a mis
en oeuvre le premier projet qui a
finalement fonctionné deux communautés
européennes celle du charbon et de
l'acier d'abord il a été le premier qui
est arrivé avec un projet concret qui a
qui a fonctionné parce qu'il y avait eu
des videmment depuis longtemps des idées
de pacifier l'europe déjà après la
première guerre mondiale même victor
hugo par l'est des états unis d'europe
mais les projets étaient des des voeux
pieux peut-être mais qui n'était pas
assez concret pour fonctionner et jean
monnet a eu ce projet concret de
travailler sur les matières premières
importantes dont on a besoin pour se
faire la guerre le charbon et l'acier et
en mettant en commun entre la france et
l'allemagne d'abord et ensuite rejoints
par d'autres pays
ces ressources primaires jambon et
l'acier et bien on garantissait
évidemment la paix entre les entre les
premiers producteurs de ces matières
sommes qu'au début les parts que
l'europe doit faire pour connaître enfin
l'unité la prospérité et la paix et puis
s'est appuyé aussi sur des hommes
politiques courageux comme robert
schuman qui ont porté le projet
politiquement parce que jean monnet
n'était pas un homme politique c'était
plutôt un concepteur de projets constant
seul regret quand on est eurodéputé
quand vous est-ce qu'on s'intéresse à
ces parcours des pères fondateurs est ce
que parfois on se replonge dans ce qui
était à la base le projet européen voulu
par ses personnages historiques
est ce que c'est important de se
rappeler de ces idées là ses premières
idées qui ont construit aujourd'hui
l'europe telle qu'on la connaît c'est
essentiel alors je vous avouerai que je
ne relis pas tous les matins les
scieries et de jean monnet où la
déclaration de robert schuman même si
régulièrement et pas que une fois par an
plus régulièrement un peu cela je la
relis et pas uniquement à l'occasion de
son anniversaire le 9 mai mais bien
évidemment quand on s'intéresse vraiment
en profondeur à la conscience européenne
on doit plonger dans
le coeur de cette histoire européenne
savoir d'où l'on vient savoir ce qui a
été notre passé douloureux guerrier ô
combien meurtriers des guerres civiles
européennes qui sont allés jusqu'au gel
aussi trois guerres entre la france et
l'allemagne
et puis il faut se plonger également
bien sûr dans le parcours et les
engagements et les écrits de
quelques-uns des pères fondateurs il ya
quelques mères fondatrices également
également on aura l'occasion d'en parler
dans d'autres émissions
est ce que dans cette période un peu
mouvementée pour l'europe qu'il est
qu'ils aient beaucoup même est-ce que
c'est aussi important de se rappeler de
ça 2 2 pourquoi l'europe a été
construite et de ne pas oublier ce volet
historique très important de ne pas
oublier effectivement pourquoi on a
travaillé après des conflits meurtriers
encore une fois la troisième guerre
franco allemande qui a déclenché une
deuxième guerre mondiale
pourquoi on a souhaité travailler à la
réconciliation entre les peuples
français et allemand et donc à la
européens pourquoi après on a souhaité
abroger le rideau de fer
faire tomber je dirais la prison des
peuples dans laquelle se trouvait trop
de nos compatriotes et européens
en europe centrale et orientale mais le
plus important quand même c'est de
pleinement prendre conscience que nous
sommes passés du xxème et xxième siècle
et que autant c'est important de se
nourrir du passé parce qu'il faut savoir
d'où l'on vient et il faut avoir des
racines et des valeurs profondes ont
créé jeudi rémi tour à tour garde les
voilà l'avenir on est entré dans un
nouveau monde
on est entré dans un nouveau siècle on a
changé de monde parfait de transition va
évoquer justement maintenant l'actualité
européenne et l'actualité en ce moment
du vieux continent c'est un regain de
tensions entre certains pays et la
russie et je pense évidemment à la
france on a l'impression d'être revenu
deux ans en arrière à l'époque de la
crise guinéenne
vadimir poutine devait se rendre en
france 19 octobre prochain il a annulé
sa venue à paris
les points de désaccord sont nombreux on
va les évoquer mais selon vous constance
le grip quelle position doit adopter
aujourd'hui face à la russie est ce
qu'on doit voilà fixé les lignes rouges
à ne pas franchir ou alors est-ce qu'il
faut se montrer conciliant avec la
russie qui continue à discuter avec
certainement pas se montrer conciliant
et quand on est un grand pays comme la
france on n'a absolument pas vocation à
se montrer conciliant avec qui que ce
soit mais par contre prenez le dialogue
prôné la fermeté mais en ayant toujours
la main tendue pour tenter de comprendre
et de ne pas ressusciter je ne sais
quelle guerre froide mais être dans
quelque chose qui puisse construire
valablement l'avenir et notamment le
retour de la paix par exemple en syrie
ça me semble être la mission historique
de la france et moi je vous laisse avec
l'art la guerre à la russie non on
ressuscite pas forcément on parle pas de
déclaration de guerre mais les tensions
aujourd'hui la façon de faire de la
diplomatie française et notamment de
françois hollande qui a dit je ne sais
pas si je vais recevoir vladimir et
durable honnêtement je condamne
très fermement cette espèce de valse
hésitation de la diplomatie française je
ne fais là aucun jeu de mot mal placé et
baissent pas mais cette valse hésitation
de la diplomatie française et de
françois hollande c'est incompréhensible
et en plus nous sommes arrivés en ce
moment très précis à accomplir une
espèce de performance entre guillemets
que je qualifierais plutôt de contre
performance nous sommes actuellement et
simultanément ça n'était jamais arrivé
notre histoire
fâché et avec la pologne et avec la
russie excusez du peu qu'elle contre
performance absolue pour la france et
vente de matériel une usine de
actuellement en froid et avec la pologne
avec la visite ça n'était jamais arrivé
c'est quand même une atmosphère de fin
de règne qui commence à entacher
gravement la crédibilité et le
rayonnement de notre pays
alors le sujet de tension numéro entre
la russie et la france est évidemment le
dossier syrien la russie a mis son veto
à un projet porté par la france deux
opéras le l'onu on parle toujours des
états unis dans ce cas-là de la russie
de la france si on se demande un peu où
est l'europe ou alors la voix de
l'europe est ce que concrètement sur un
dossier comme la syrie et plus
généralement sur les dossiers
internationaux l'europe n'existe pas
alors il est vrai que c'est une gageure
que de réaliser une politique étrangère
européenne commune il y as depuis
l'entrée en vigueur du traité lisbonne
depuis quelques années un haut
responsable en l'occurrence une autre
représentante c'est une rude réduit joue
le rôle avec tous les guillemets qu'il
convient de mettre de super aux
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne et qui tentent
d'harmoniser de dégager une voie
européenne commune
c'est très difficile bien évidemment
c'est un défi permanent sur certains
dossiers est plus facile parce qu'il
utilisera qui rechignent à laisser qui
que nous avons des grandes politiques
diplomatiques dans un centre détail à 28
diplomatie importante est
extraordinairement actives est important
d'un qui est à 28 à remirent qui ont un
véritable rôle européen international à
jouer enfin nous avons effectivement des
siècles des siècles d'histoire
diplomatique l'histoire d'engagement
international
dans ce concert des nations européennes
et s'agit pas d' écraser d'étouffer de
gommer tout ça mais plutôt de voir
comment transcender éventuellement
quelques divergences quelques
différences et mettre tout ce qui est en
harmonie l'heure sur certains dossiers
on est arrivé je pense notamment par
exemple ou très difficile dossier
iranien de la sûreté nucléaire en iran
où tout au début du début mais ça
remonte à il ya des années et des années
c'était l'union européenne est ravi et
cela marque était le prédécesseur avait
besoin de madame nos guérini qui avait
initié un dialogue dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles extrêmement
exigeante avec les rangs et qu'après on
a vu d'autres grandes puissances les
etats-unis théâtre donc de temps en
temps quand on arrive à se mettre
d'accord et qu'on arrive à cerner
n'autoriser commun on peut arriver à
dégager les voies et moyens d'une vraie
européenne le dossier syrien les
européens n'arrivent pas à se mettre
d'accord puisque on connaît les
conséquences aujourd'hui honnie dont on
sait les crises migratoires non on est
au sort tous les européens mais pourtant
cacophonie non ya pas de cacophonie sur
le dossier syrien personne mais c'est la
bonne humeur au dnc ça bloque pas que la
france mais il se trouve que la france
est militairement très engagé et nous
avons des hommes et les femmes nos
valeureux soldats qui sont prêts à
mourir pour défendre ensemble de valeurs
et à se tendre de positions qui ne sont
pas que française au delà qui sont des
valeurs et des positions et une
politique européenne mais il n'y a pas
de cacophonie pour le coup sur le
dossier syrien il n'y a pas de
cacophonie européenne mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a des raisons historiques
les raisons militaires des raisons
diplomatiques qui fait que qui font part
donc à un moment donné on n'entend plus
un pays que nos fonctionnaires ou une
grande diplomate européenne
on faisait le lien forcément entre la
crise syrienne et la crise des migrants
en europe
quand vous voyez l'europe de l'est
toujours plus réticente à accueillir des
migrants notamment la hongrie qui a
organisé un référendum sur le sujet
invalidée mais qui a été fortement
soutenue par la population sur place
l'europe occidentale également qu'ils se
fichent sur ce sujet l'allemagne la
france depuis le début
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire on a
l'impression parfois que les valeurs de
l'europe sont bafoués sur une telle
crise est con
on ne va pas dans le sens de l'histoire
notre histoire à nous alors d'abord moi
je ne veux pas que l'on donne des leçons
à l'europe et aux peuples européens
l'europe est le continent monde le plus
ouvert celui qui a toujours accueilli le
plus de réfugiés et de migrants et qui
continue à accueillir propres semences à
brühl à sion le plus de réfugiés et de
migrants
ces quelque 1 million 500 mille
approximativement migrants réfugiés se
meurt en allemagne en suède et très peu
dans le reste des pays qui sont dans les
normes opus le pays européens mais
effectivement épique épiant vous oubliez
la grèce ou l'italie qui sont quand même
à notre bordure extérieure et qui sont
en réalité des premiers concernés par
l'accueil dans les conditions souvent
extrêmement difficile cela implique des
efforts et dépense d'énergie incroyable
qui sont en première ligne je dirais nos
amis grecs et nos amis italiens dans
l'accueil des milliers
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés et de
migrants avec d'ailleurs le besoin de
clarifier un petit peu les choses encore
une fois ne donnons pas de leçons à
l'europe et moi je n'accepte pas les
leçons venu peut-être d'autres régions
du monde
nous avons toujours et nous continuons à
accueillir les demandeurs d'asile celles
et ceux qui avaient tant besoin d'un
refuge politique et qui peuvent donc
valablement prétendre à obtenir le
statut de réfugiés politiques ou le
statut de réfugié de guerre mais en même
temps nous devons dire que nous n'avons
pas vocation à accueillir tous les
migrants illégaux qui viennent dans des
ados de mort d'ailleurs souvent parce
qu'il traverse et opérer de leur vie la
méditerranée mais encore une fois il y a
nécessité je pense d'eux et je regrette
qu'on ait tant et tant tardé et que
surtout on est attendus tous ces drames
humains
née de l'éclatement de la syrie de
l'aggravation de la situation sur la
rive sud de la méditerranée en libye en
irak et ailleurs pour véritablement se
rendre compte mais dans la douleur et
dans l'urgence de la nécessité de
définir entre nous une politique
européenne commune en matière d'asile et
d'immigration cela aiderait ligne de
fracture entre certains pays et d'autre
entre l'europe de l'est peut-être et
plus l'europe de l'ouest même si je me
disais aujourd'hui l'allemagne semble
faire machine arrière
il n'y a pas de on disait tout à l'heure
sur le dossier syrien on est tous
d'accord mais alors sur l'équipement et
diplomatiquement parlant oui il ya une
seule lui sur la façon d'agir sur notre
territoire là on est pas on n'est pas
d'accord
je crois qu'aucun pays européen ne se
soustrait aux obligations du droit
international et n'a pas vocation à
accueillir sur son sol les
monde d'asile politique maintenant qu'il
puisse y avoir je le reconnais et je
peut en comprendre les raisons de fortes
réticences quant aux mécanismes
d'allocation de quotas obligatoires
parce que c'est de cela qu'il s'agit et
c'est là-dessus essentiellement qu'avait
pu supporter la question sociale avec
norman au peuple hongrois le mécanisme
de quotas fortement obligations
apportées par la commission européenne
et états
je peux comprendre et partager les
réticences parce que honnêtement on
marche un peu sur la tête je le dis
franchement sans diplomatie excessive
des quotas en matière d'immigration ou
en matière d'accueil de réfugiés
ça ne peut pas être selon la vente de
cette offre et à la non mais ça ne peut
pas être un préalable à une nouvelle
politique européenne d'asile et
d'immigration ça peut en être la
conséquence l'un des aboutissements
mais avant même que de se mettre
d'accord sur qui veut ton accueillir
selon quelles conditions selon quel
statut de réfugié politique réfugiés de
guerre aux migrants économiques pourquoi
pas regroupement familial pourquoi pas à
vous que de se mettre d'accord sur ce
que j'appelle de mes voeux une véritable
politique européenne commune d'asile et
d'immigration
on veut imposer la commission européenne
veut imposer des quotas obligatoires
et là effectivement on est quand même
dans quelque chose qui n'est pas comment
dire caractérisée par le meilleur bon
sens moi je souhaite qu'on ait au
préalable une politique européenne
commune d'asile et d'immigration et ça
c'est urgent non seulement d'en parler
mais de la définir on a perdu des années
et des années
une très rapidement c'est un sujet aussi
qui concerne le local puisque également
dans les yvelines ya eu des
manifestations récemment pour dénoncer
l'arrivée future de migrants on parle de
800 400 nouveaux migrants plutôt saffré
800 au total sur une population de plus
d'un million de personnes
est ce que vous vous intéressez aussi à
ces inquiétudes locales est ce que vous
pencher dessus en tant qu'eurodéputé
francilienne
j'entends les inquiétudes des
populations parce qu'elles sont souvent
ils se prennet assez fortement mois
comment ne pas les entendre
et puis je comprend également les
interrogations des élus locaux des mères
qui voudraient pouvoir être entendu être
accompagnée le cas échéant être consulté
en amour je pense qu'il faut faire
preuve de considération et et
d'attention vis-à-vis de ce que peuvent
exprimer des élus locaux et les maires
et qu'il ne faut pas plaquer sur des
communes d
faculté d'accueil qui n'auraient pas été
dûment pensée du monde
élaboré avec les acteurs locaux je sais
bien qu'il ya urgence puisque le gamin
s'est engagée trop tardivement et notre
retard 10 morts au moment où la
situation était devenue totalement
intenable à démanteler le camp je n'ose
en plein dans ce mode de calais et donc
se trouve à devoir envisager quoi faire
des quelques 10000 personnes qui
s'étaient entassées de manière
parfaitement il mène d'ailleurs qu'on
avait laissé sans passer dans cet espace
clos
mais encore une fois la politique de
gribouille
quand il s'agit en plus d'hommes de
femmes et d'enfants
c'est forcément toujours extrêmement
dommageable c'est pas comme ça qu'il
aurait fallu faire une constance le grip
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
s'intéresse aujourd'hui aux différents
régimes politiques en europe et pour les
précisions c'est avec olivier jeanne
l'ex responsable du centre d'information
europe direct de saint germain en laye
en europe on trouve différents types de
régime on a une première distinction
entre les monarchies constitutionnelles
et les républiques donc les monarchies
constitutionnelles se sont tout
simplement en fait des régimes
politiques
en fait on a un souverain qui joue un
rôle essentiellement on va dire
symbolique d'unités de la nation et où
en fait c'est le parlement qui va élire
un chef de gouvernement comme ce qu'on
connaît par exemple au royaume uni avec
le premier ministre qui lui va conduire
la politique de la nation
au niveau des républiques on peut avoir
un président qui peut avoir plus ou
moins de pouvoir en fonction d'eux en
fonction de l'organisation du régime ça
peut être comme par exemple on a le cas
en allemagne où on a un président bon
qui joue un rôle essentiellement
symbolique et où c'est le tout c'est le
chancelier allemand ou là actuellement
la chancelière allemand qui dirige la
politique de la nation où on peut aussi
avoir par exemple l'exemple chypriote
tout c'est tout simplement là où c'est
le président qui va conduire la
politique ou en fait est là il n'y a pas
de premier ministre à on a enfin une
dernière distinction entre ce qu'on
appelle des régimes monocaméral est
bicaméral alors tout simplement c'est de
savoir s'il ya une chambre où plusieurs
chambres au niveau du parlement
par exemple on a le cas en finlande où
le parlement des constitué que d'une
chambre ou donc là c'est un régime
monocaméral et donc on a des régimes
bicaméral par exemple comme en france ou
en fait on a deux chambres où on à la
chambre basse qui représente on va dire
les citoyens le peuple donc c'est
l'assemblée l'assemblée nationale et où
on à la chambre haute qui alors
représentant fonction des pays qui peut
représenter différentes choses pour nous
en france on a l'habitude de dire que
c'est un peu une sorte de chambre de
sagesse en roumanie ou en fait là c'est
le sénat qui représente tout simplement
les départements qui représente les
départements roumains ou au royaume uni
où l'as tout simplement ça représente
les lords ce que ça implique notamment
c'est que si c'est un régime bicaméral
on a un système de navettes entre les
textes c'est à dire qu'en fait que quand
un texte est passé par une chambre il
faut qu'il soit voté exactement dans les
mêmes termes par l'autre chambre et
ainsi de suite
et des fois on peut avoir plusieurs
navettes le temps d'arriver à un
compromis sur le même texte tandis que
si on n'a qu'une chambre ben là c'est
c'est plus simple il ya juste à obtenir
l'accord une fois d'une seule chambre
l'italie s'était alors c'est un régime
parlementaire bicamérale parfait c'est à
dire qu'en fait entre la chambre des
députés italienne et le sénat le sénat
italien il ya un équilibre des pouvoirs
parfait c'est à dire que s'il ya une
chambre qui bloque l'autre ne le travail
législatif ne peut pas avancer
c'est notamment une précaution qui avait
été mise en place à la suite suite à la
chute du fascisme pour éviter justement
de retomber dans ses travers la
actuellement le premier ministre italien
matteo renzi souhaiterait faire évoluer
soit très faire évoluer ce système
notamment en supprimant le sénat afin
justement d'améliorer le travail
législatif afin de le rendre plus
efficace que ça ait beaucoup plus vital
et cette émission se veut également
interactive l'europe est souvent l'objet
de reproches trop complexe passe assez
transparente voire parfois inutiles et
bien nous donnons la parole à des
acteurs de la vie locale dans les
yvelines
et pour vous poser une première question
sur l'europe vous avez benoît hamon sur
la petite table est juste la députée
socialiste de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines je vous propose de l'écouter
bonjour benoît vraiment député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
circonstances le gris je voudrais vous
interroger sur une question il semble
qu'ils ce que dégage un consensus peut
être dans n'êtes vous pas mais en tout
cas un consensus en france autour du
rejet du taffetas si on rejette le taf
talent très très libre échange avec les
états unis
pourquoi faire le cétacé terre le traité
de libre-échange avec le canada
et pourquoi poursuivre aussi sur la
libéralisation des services là où on
considère que finalement ça a plus
d'inconvénients plus d'impact négatif
pour l'emploi est davantage donc que
ferez vous sur le ceta
alors cette question de benoît hamon
députés socialistes c'est le taffetas
aujourd'hui travail est en suspens on en
parle pour moi qu'on puisse dire un il a
été très sérieusement mis au frigidaire
c'est à lui par les américains eux mêmes
d'ailleurs on parle aussi les européens
qui étaient fortune était de plus en
plus réticents c'est moi qu'on visionne
et je partageais d'ailleurs et les
inquiétudes et les réticences quant à la
non évolution des négociations et aux
portes fermées que les négociateurs
renvoyer à la figure
ce n'est pas qu'un sur le c'est à cet
accord entre le canada et l'europe qui
sera signé fin octobre par les états
européens et le canada il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude cette fois ci sur des
normes sociétales environnementales qui
ne sont pas forcément les mêmes du côté
de nantes loire-atlantique frites les
accords commerciaux ne concerne pas les
normes sociétales un conte et des enjeux
de normalisation mais il n'est pas
question de questions sociétales
le cédant est d'après ce que j'en ai
compris
je ne sais pas une spécialiste de
politique commerciale mais enfin j'ai
quand même pris la peine de regarder de
très près ce dossier de beaucoup écouté
de beaucoup entendre de beaucoup pu
rencontrer d'interlocuteurs d'acteurs
économiques d'acteurs agricole et de
beaucoup discuté avec ma collègue
apparaît quand même comme un accord qui
a été très longuement et très
minutieusement discuter négocier et qui
au final est un accord qui peut s'avérer
extrêmement positive qui va vraiment
jeter des ponts entre
bloc de l'europe union européenne et
l'énorme marché
l'énorme contrée qui est le canada et
qu'il ya toute une série de mesures sur
lesquelles nous sommes parvenus à faire
prévaloir auprès de nos amis canadiens
nos vues il ya par exemple sur c'était
très important et c'est l'une des
raisons pour lequel les négociations
entre les états unis et l'europe
n'avance et du tout du tout du tout nous
avons réussi avec le canada à mettre en
place un mécanisme d'arbitrage
d'éventuels conflits entre entreprises
et états tout à fait satisfaisant
intéressant qui n'a rien à voir les
mécanismes d'arbitrage privé tels qu'ils
existaient depuis des décennies dans une
multinationale quelque chose qui
correspond tout à fait à ce que
d'ailleurs le parlement européen mme
avait eu cesse de réclamer depuis
environ 18 mois qui est un mécanisme
d'arbitrage avec des magistrats
professionnels indépendants et c'est
donc sur toute une série de sujets qui à
juste titre compte alimenter les
réserves de ne pas dire l'inquiétude
voire la franche hostilité des projets
d'accords euros états unis on a avec le
canada surmonter les épreuves surmonter
les obstacles et donc quand viendra
devant le parlement européen puisqu'il
sera quelque chose de non je sais pas ce
que ça vienne aussi rapidement enfin
vous savez l'ordre du jour mieux que moi
mais en face à va venir effectivement
certainement avant la fin de cette année
la ratification
je voterai en faveur de la ratification
du 7 ans mais je redis comme l'ensemble
ma famille politique puisque le taffetas
type on l'appelle comme on veut
le projet d'accord etats unis europe les
choses étaient tellement mal engagée les
élections françaises également project
est devenu urgent de mettre sur pause
nous avons mis sur pause merci constance
legris d'avoir participé à 7,8 politique
version europe je rappelle que vous avez
est évidemment eurodéputés les
républicains et d'ile-de-france prochain
7,8 politique
le 28 octobre depuis le lot
de guyancourt dans les yvelines nous
reviendrons ici au parlement européen le
11 novembre avec pervenche berès
eurodéputés socialistes
d'ici là vous pouvez retrouver toutes
nos émissions sur tv fil 78 points comme
au revoir